any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
great well it's a great it's a great
pleasure to welcome noam chomsky to the
into the impossible podcast which is a
production of the university of
california san diego's arthur c
clarke center for human imagination
we've been doing this for
over a decade and uh or so and the
podcast is relatively
recent and the name into the impossible
podcast takes its name from
one of sir arthur c clarke's famous
three laws
uh the first one being any sufficiently
advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
the second law of sir arthur was for
every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert and
the third law
is the only way to find out what is
possible is to venture
a bit beyond into the impossible and i
thank you for
agreeing to come on and we're gonna
maybe touch upon the
different areas that interested sir
arthur c clarke
uh in particular the melding of multiple
cultures
writing uh technology and science um
these these different aspects that we
perceive as disparate
but uh perhaps there are some uh common
threads that we can pull on and
uh in doing so reveal more about the
underlying
nature of these intellectual pursuits
that you've been participating in for
for
many decades i should first say welcome
gnome thank you so much for coming on
glad to be with you this is the second
time we've met we met in 2017
at the science of consciousness
conference organized by stuart hameroff
who's a mutual friend
and he had the or um the conference that
was held here in 2017 when you were here
and i was speaking
uh featured a brain uh riding a
surfboard
as the logo of the of the conference
and i want to talk a little bit about
some ideas that i haven't stopped
thinking about since you gave
that that lecture back in 2017
and i want to uh couple that to these
thoughts about consciousness
and how it intersects with your
specialty of linguistics
linguistic reasoning etc but before we
do that for most of my listeners are in
the
physical sciences uh some are you know
culturally interested
in aspects of art and we've had on
guests ranging from pulitzer prize
winning poets to
nobel prize winning astrophysicist but
we've never had a linguist on and i
wonder
if it's possible for you to give a brief
overview of why linguistics
is important and what inspired you many
years ago to pursue it
the it's been understood for millennia
actually that since classical greece
that possession of language is the
uh almost the defining characteristic of
human beings
it's a species property it's common to
all humans
who's assumed for centuries that it's
common to all humans now we have good
evidence for it
there's doesn't seem to be any group
variation
it's a apparently a very recent
development
last couple hundred maybe 200 000 years
ago
roughly about that which is nothing in
evolutionary time
it has it is its properties have no
analog in the animal world
essentially none so it's a true species
property
common to humans distinctive of humans
and it's the core of our creative
capacities uh
the reasons why people get nobel prizes
are thinking it's just central to all of
our lives
so if you follow the uh elfic oracle
let's say
and assume that our goal is
know thyself then this is the place to
look
and in the context of linguistics i have
a couple of things again i
i beg your forbearance as we proceed to
things that are possibly of interest to
me but uh and me alone but
these will be related to my role as a
father
of many young children and uh and and
some of the
constructs are hypotheses that i've
tried to test
throughout unwittingly using my children
as experimental
uh research uh subjects but uh perhaps
we'll get to those in a little bit
i think uh what was so interesting to me
is that you drew
a connection in your 2017 talk uh
between consciousness
and linguistics and i wonder uh first of
all
is it uh is it possible in a sense to
uh to link a mathematical
uh construct of what is linguism or what
is linguistically
um a a statement that can be proven
because it seems to me that there are or
vast relevancies between
linguistics and mathematics and that's
no accident you contributed a lot to the
quantitative
interpretation of it but uh let me let
me uh flesh out what i'm trying to
explain uh in mathematics according to
girdle it's possible to prove
that there is an incompleteness in
mathematical
uh formal logic that you uh there'll be
statements that cannot be
uh could not be proven consistently
within
the system of formal mathematics itself
is there an analog of girdles in
completeness theorem
uh in linguistics is there uh is there
a formal system that can define what is
outside the bounds of linguistics or is
it
uh just a com combination of
uh neurological motor skills etc
um how is there a relevant or is there
an
analog of girdles theorem for
linguistics
it's not really gurdle's theorem which
only applies in
very specifically defined formal systems
languages not a foreign
so of course it doesn't apply but in
fact
in california once i spent some time
with alfred
tarski and he couldn't understand why
anybody understands language because you
can formulate the logic
but the liar's paradox you know so
you're interested in but it's an
organic system you're interested in its
properties
you can immediately find things that
aren't in it
by looking at its properties take a look
at the visual system
begin to understand it now you can find
things that aren't going to be
accommodated by the visual system
but has nothing to do with girls theorem
that's just
that's what happens when you look at any
physical entity
and the language system encoded in the
brain is just one
physical entity so we can find we can
search for its properties we will find
things that
are outside those properties in fact you
can there's very interesting work on
this incidentally
even neuroscientific
neuro-linguistic work so for example you
can construct
formal invented languages which violate
the principles of the universal
principles of human language
and then you can ask what happens when
people are exposed to these
insistence and you get some interesting
results
so for example one of the deepest and
in some ways most surprising properties
of language
is that the rules of the core
rules of language the part of language
that is concerned with
basically constructing thoughts is
you go back a step you can divide
the language system into basically two
parts
one part is concerned with constructing
linguistic expressions which are
expressions of thought
the other part is externalizing it to
some sensory motor system it's kind of
like the
internal program in your laptop and the
printer you
attach it to you can attach it to one or
another printer
and in fact the internal system of
language
we happened to be using speech but if we
were deaf we'd be using sign
and it's essentially comparable it's
just a different printer
it's the same internal system so if we
keep the
internal system the core of language
turns out it pays no attention to things
like linear order
only pays attention to the structure of
expressions
which has a very funny consequence it
means that your children for example
when they're acquiring language pay no
attention
to 100 of what they hear and only pay
attention to what they never hear
they hear things in linear order but the
rules that they use pay attention to
structure
which they don't hear they construct it
in their minds
now this principle called structure
dependence
allows you right away to develop
impossible languages
namely languages that use linear order
so for example you could construct a
language which is
like ordinary language except the way it
uses negation
say is not the way ordinary language is
do
by structural positions but rather by
linear order
so suppose you invent a language which
in which
if you want to negate a sentence the
third word with
transcends will be not okay
that's a trivial problem to solve
but if you give it to him to humans in
invented languages
turns out that they can solve the
problem as a puzzle
but the language areas of the brain are
not the ones that are activated
rather you get diffuse activation is for
puzzle solving
uh if you give them a invented language
which keeps to the
rules of ordinary language then they can
learn it but the language areas
at work so there you can find you can
indeed study
impossible languages and the way the
brain reacts to them
and uh this is what strikes one of the
most striking examples in fact
one thing i wanted to discuss maybe
segway's into it and i'm sorry to use up
my
uh my uh my perhaps one request that
your forbearance uh so
soon in our conversation gnome but um i
wanted i was thinking about the
communication problem the so-called
communicating with extraterrestrial
intelligence
and i want to understand if you have a
perspective on this because
as you make the case so often a lot of
language is as you're saying is
is not even the verbal or structural or
even the the
linear processes by which language can
be acquired
by human beings and uh and yet
if you imagine the problem of
communicating with an extraterrestrial
civilization using
purely using a printer or using binary
code or some such
uh form of flashing uh lights converted
into
into morse code perhaps is it
and assuming the intelligence could
decipher such a thing first of all
assuming they exist by the way do you
believe that there are extraterrestrial
civilizations
i promise this won't be a long uh what's
that
fear me bird yes do you believe that
they exist or
do you have a reason to suspect that
they might not
intelligent communicating technological
intelligence they may
in fact they may be all up there if they
have any intelligence
and they pay any attention to what's
going on on earth
they'll get far away with people as
creatures like us that's right i think
that's probably the answer to the fermi
paradox
as a joke but there may be
extra maybe not and then assuming that
notice intelligence is a very rare
property uh you may have seen
ernst meyer's article on this responding
to
carl sagan you've seen that
discussion interesting discussion so
carl sagan's from a point of view and
astrophysicists is
it's got to be all these planets out
there very much like ours
it's got to be like this now meyer from
the point of view of biologists he was
the grand old man of american biology
says well
maybe but he says we have one case that
we
know about earth there have been about
50 billion species some of them are
biological biologically successful that
means they survive and proliferate
some of them are not the ones that
survive and proliferate are the dumb
ones
things like bacteria mutate very quickly
no problems or say beetles
you remember old dane's famous comment
that
god must have loved beetles he made so
many of them right
they're fine they find a niche they just
stick to it and
they get by but as you go up the scale
of what we call
intelligence survival gets lower and
lower
large mammals for example are very rare
the only reason there's a lot of cows is
because we domesticate them
but if you look at wild in the wild
say apes very few
they don't survive very well and if you
take
humans it's probably only the last
couple hundred thousand years
which means that several billion years
of life went by and never know humans
nothing with what we call higher
intelligence
that's right to extrapolate and ask what
might happen on other planets
chances of developing higher
intelligence might not be very high
yeah they just might not survive and
even if they're intelligent it doesn't
mean that they're technologically
advanced um that they're able to
interpret
and feel build devices you know i always
say it takes
you can't build a solar panel you know
solar panels weren't built
using solar panels to provide power in
other words
there's a hierarchy of energy scales
that were needed to construct something
as sophisticated or not as a
photovoltaic cell
tiny percentage of human life
but let's suppose that they that there's
something like
human intelligence there would there be
ways to communicate
well i think the thing to do is not to
look at the printer
no they could have used one just like
humans we can use one or another sensory
motor system
we can use our hands you can use
touch you can even learn language from
touch
yes you can learn we use sound because
it's convenient
you use some other so i don't really
think that's the issue
the issue is the internal system
a system that constructs infinitely many
thoughts basically
and if you look at that there's a
good reason to think that there might be
a mode of interaction
namely arithmetic if you take a look at
the structure of language
it's the internal system
there's pretty good evidence by now that
it's based on the most
elementary computational
device namely binary set formation
and if you take a look at binaries from
that you can construct the infinitely
many structures and so on
and if you take a look at that you can
from
binary set formation with a lexicon of
one element you basically get the basis
for arithmetic
uh there's a kind of another direction
from which you could look at this
uh marv minsky
50 or 60 years ago did some
experiments in which he just took the
simplest touring machines
fewest states and
and uh symbols and asked what happens if
you just let them run wild
you know turns out almost all of them
crash
either they get into an infinite cycle
or they
or they terminate uh but some
survive and turned out they all had the
successor function
so and then he concludes well suppose
evolution is getting to the point where
it's
developing systems that have
some of the capacities of turing
machines
it's going to hit on the simplest things
and the simplest things will give you
something like the basis for arithmetic
and maybe they'll give you language
that's
a point where there's possible
convergence
in order to pursue it you have to show
that so for example this point i made
about structure dependence
that actually follows directly from the
fact that the
basic computational system for language
is
minor reset formation because that does
not yield linear order
so if that's the system that's in your
child's brain it's never going to use
linear order
it'll use it for communication but
that's because of the sensory motor
system
the sensory motor system requires linear
order
we can't talk in structures so you have
to linearize the thing
but that's a property the printer has
basically nothing to do with language
sensory motor system was in place
hundreds of thousands millions of years
before language emerge
and it's basically nothing to do with it
just as your printer has nothing to do
with the
program and the laptop
so in in the absence of all systems
though uh
so the absence of a neural mechanistic
touch uh sound uh with these aliens it
merely communicating only with
arithmetic um
you know symbolic symbolic logic that
would be
sufficient i assume that they have
some mode of externalizing what's in
their heads
now if we can latch on to that mode
of communication that
printer that they're using then we could
go back to the internal system
it's good reason to believe that they
would have the successor function
in addition because the successor
function addition it's part of our
language
so maybe that should be an entry point
interesting so you mentioned um
you mentioned artificial intelligence
hopefully we'll get to around to that
in a little bit um are there you know
subject models
um do does linguistics benefit from
from as i know um uh colleagues here at
uc san diego have
studied you know consciousness and and
uh sensory perception
uh in in subjects that have had damage
to their brains and
and the problems that they illustrate
have revealed patterns
of of uh understanding of how actually
the brain
works and i'm wondering is that the case
in linguistics too
are there uh deficiencies in in subjects
that
from from which you learn more about how
uh those of us who are blessed not to
have deficiencies in that realm
uh how we actually process language
well there's quite a lot of work done
language pathologies deficiencies of one
sort of other
its work actually began about
50 years ago with some classic work
by eric leneberg a old friend of mine
who founded
with the modern biology of language and
there's a great deal of recent work on
it
so there so let's
take one example there's a well-studied
case of a
subject called his name
the name that's given to him is chris
he's a young
man who has virtually
extremely limited cognitive capacities
but he can do almost nothing
but he has amazing linguistic capacities
him to a language learns it very quickly
he's mastered dozens of languages and
he's
kind of obsessed with it all he wants to
do is learn another language
actually they tried this test with him
that i mentioned before
about impossible languages so
the language that you give if you and
they tried the same test with chris
so give him an invented language you've
never seen before
or even an invented language that keeps
to the linguistic principles
learns it very quickly given
a system which uses something like
linear order for negation or other
violations of structure dependence
total blank you can't make any progress
not because you can't solve
puzzles and there are
lots of different kinds of cases um
there are
cases of subjects who have almost no
cortex
tiny amount of cortex but complete
language capacity
you know i mean this actually
just began with the study of aphasia
back in the
early 19th century and but since then
there's been
especially since leonard's work
extensive study of
a range of different language
pathologies and the effects that they
have
so i want to get into some other
speculations perhaps
not as well founded as some of the other
topics we'll get into when we come back
to your
talk on consciousness um when
uh is is it true that um you know
richard feynman used to say that
uh he was surprised when he realized
that not everybody counted the way that
he counted
in other words i believe he would count
and he would hear in his mind
uh the numbers one two three etc
and he realized that that was you know
that was just the way that he
visualized or heard numbers if you will
and that's the way that he counted
he realized that some of his colleagues
at mit or you know
fellow students that they would see
numbers moving across their mind
is is there um is there oh first of all
there there is this continuing running
monologue
that i always say you know if somebody
heard my inner monologue
you know they might think i'm saying you
know if i if they didn't hear it but
they certainly wouldn't feel i'm saying
you know just the endless bombardment of
of language
is it uh is it the case though as with
feynman's you know finding
uh do people some people see words or
you know
when they're when they're having these
internal monologues you've spoken about
uh in the past or do they merely hear
them
kind of the way i do uh is is that
something that's universal or is it does
it you know
bimodal and some people hear it some
people see it how do people
um let me ask you a question when you're
typing a letter not paying a lot of
attention you know and just typing not
paying much attention
do you ever notice that you make
typographical errors where you
type a word that sounds the same way
yeah isn't like you you suppose you're
planning to say write w-r-i-t-e would
you write
r-i-g-h-t sometimes yeah does that mean
i'm crazy or they should be committed or
that's me too i think what it means is
you're hearing the things
i think you're writing but you're
actually hearing
and that writing is a kind of a very
peripheral activity hearing is much
deeper embedded writing is just
it's even more remote than the printer
you know
it's a way of mapping the printer into
something else
secondary printer so actually when you
are doing something like
typing you're often just hearing
yourself and
that's why you make mistakes like that
are there differences in the way people
do this
as far as i know it hasn't been
investigated much it's
way out of the periphery one of the deep
questions or
you know what's going on with the kind
of things we're talking about before
yeah if some if you have certain kind of
brain injury
what's that going to do to your language
faculty
here there's lots of work are there any
analogs in
you know ramachandran's brief tour of
human consciousness he speaks a lot
about you know
synesthesia and and kind of pathological
circumstances
brain injuries people will you know
smell the color orange or things like
that
have the linguistic differences between
such patients been studied in other
words you know how does it affect their
ability to do just what we said you know
typing writing hearing
seeing
at the level of typing i've never seen
anything
but the level of speech errors it's so
cool
there's quite a lot of work actually
susan curtis and
your university is one of the leading
specialists on this
cadet yeah
and i definitely like to have her on the
podcast as well
uh so um getting you know just a couple
more language
um you know maybe popular myths or
whatever
as i said i have many children and i'm
very
fortunate to have so many but uh i've i
heard it once said by a mathematician
that he uh he made sure to speak
several thousand words a day to his
children
uh and that they he believed that there
had been some studies that showed that
children begin to speak only after
they've heard a million words so
that would be a year's worth of 3000
words a day roughly so
you're shaking your head so i guess
almost nothing good
actually what the studies show is the
children they
don't pay much attention to what their
parents are saying
they pay the ambient environment
but you can ask yourself i don't know
your background
but take say my background my parents
were immigrants
yeah so they're they knew english
perfectly well but with accents
i don't speak like them i talk like the
kids on the street
a good dialectician could figure out
quickly that i come from northeast
philadelphia
not from ukraine and
that's pretty nobody understands why but
children
usually pick up the dialect of their
peers
and not really the parents try to train
them
and the kids may listen within those
ordinary
behavior and very little impact of
uh parents efforts there was at one
point a belief in
the child language literature that
there's something that used to be called
mother ease
mothers talk to children in very special
ways and
that's supposed to help them learn but
as the careful studies took place it
turned out
the kids just weren't paying any
attention so
there's a there's another myth that
children start learning language in
utero
i guess from what you just said that is
true
well they learn something so fast what
they learn
in utero is probably
prosody
but what the experimental evidence is
that shows
with the work of jacques mcclare the
french cognitive scientists
you take a two month two day old child
about as early as you can begin to test
anything
and the tests usually have to do with
the intensity of sucking it's about the
only thing you can measure
you get surprise reactions if
uh the intensity of sucking increases
means the
infant is interested so you can
distinguish things that cause surprise
from those who done
and just using that experimental
technique
that he was able to show that a
two-day-old
infant can distinguish the language of
its mother
from uh the same
from the same language spoken by a
perfectly a different language spoken by
a bilingual
woman who speaks the
both that language and the second
language he could just
the infant could distinguish the voice
he's never heard
talking his mother's language and
talking some different language
and since then there's been that shows
something's going on in utero
and since then there's been quite a lot
of study of it and it turns out it's
it's not the actual language it's a
certain category of languages ones that
have
similar exotic structure uh
this has even gone to the point of
people putting
uh sound devices on the uterus of a cow
and seeing what you can hear when you
hear sort of muffled speech
so you can something's coming through
that's
that the infant is picking up something
about it the point is that children are
pre-programmed to acquire language
it's a very striking fact that i mean an
ape for example a chimpanzee
has about the same auditory systems
humans
and uh if you put it if you give in
an ape and an infant exactly the same
uh environment where the infant
immediately hears speech and picks up
language
in a regular fashion almost reflexively
they just hears a noise doesn't matter
how much training you do
can't do anything so it's just an
internal
your your genetically approached child
is genetically programmed to
pick up all the noise in the environment
and say i'm going to be looking at this
and as i said it's kind of striking but
in fact an infant doesn't pay attention
to
100 of what it hears linear order
pays attention to it it never hears the
structure that
its brain constructs which is a pretty
dramatic finding
are there languages this is the last of
the myths that i'm going to ask you to
bust or
or i don't know what the opposite is but
uh bolster um
there uh i had a phenomenal professor of
uh
high energy particle physics when i was
a graduate student at brown university
since deceased uh kian so kang and he
used to tell us in a you know kind of a
mercurial smile on his face he used to
say korean
is the most logical language because the
pictograms
the glyphs of the language were in some
sense reminiscent of the
facial motor system that was to be
employed in the position of the tongue
etc
is that a myth or does that have any
validity
there's some truth to it but it's not
about language it's about the writings
the writings yes right right it's very
peripheral language
writing is a very recent phenomenon
under
a very small part of the human
population until recently
and it's true that the korean writing
system
does not so much facial expressions but
it does
reflect the phonological properties
to an unusual perspective and an unusual
uh uh like extend to the green level
so there's something to it but it has
essentially nothing to do with language
right that's pure writing yeah but i
guess in the sense of
um the written language as a tool for
acquisition
of verbal language i mean there there's
some at least peripheral
knowledge if i can read the language and
i can write in the language it
may you know assist in some of the
breakdown of some of the cognates
perhaps
especially if you translate from one
language to another but um
but notice that that's very late in
language oh yes
sure absolutely yeah the two or three
year old
has an enormous language capacity yeah
and that
aren't exhibited so for example when
infant is in what's called the two word
stage it just says two words you know
uh you know
me hungary or something yeah whatever
you know now
yeah more but
at that stage the child is understanding
much more complex sentences now you can
show that
by trying to introduce errors
into the more complex sentences the kid
can't understand it
in fact there have been studies in which
this is called telegraphic speech you
know you're talking just
none of the small words just nouns and
verbs
so you give a kid who's in the
telegraphic speech stage
uh three conditions one
normal speech one the child's own
telegraphic speech the third
telegraphic speech with the small words
randomly
introduced so three different conditions
it turns out the kid can't understand
its own speech
can't understand the random the
distributed ones but it can't understand
normal speech
because what's going on in the head is
much beyond the what's coming out of the
printer
right um and so
maybe there was uh one more um
one more comment that i had uh that was
sort of related to
popularized uh myths perhaps rather than
you know fundamental uh mysteries
and i'm trying to find in my notes oh
yeah here it is um
so we have in language uh of course it's
written but
in this particular context but um but
but
uh there is a connection to the spoken
language as well
uh there's a sense that um linguistics
if it's if it is to be
a um you know a hard discipline a
regularized discipline with the rules
etc how is that consistent with the fact
that
language at least in the realm of
vocabulary
uh changes regularly i i'm sure i was
dismayed a few weeks ago to learn that
merriam-webster's dictionary
now no longer marks as incorrect
spelling the word irregardless
which was always the bane of whenever my
students would use such a word in spoken
or
written language they now accept it and
in fact you can type it into your
computer and my computer will not flag
it as
making a spelling error or even a
grammatical error
um if we add to the vocabulary um
why is it is it is it not impossible to
imagine that even
grammatical things such as subject
subject-verb agreement
uh is that a slippery you know shifting
language zeitgeist
or are there certain laws that are
immutable
almost uh laws of nature when it comes
to language
if you don't understand something it
looks as if it varies all over the place
so if you go back say 60 years
biologists believe that organisms were
so
diverse that you have to study each one
on its own
nothing to say about them by now we know
that they're so
uniform that there's even serious
thought about the possibility of a
universal genome
because if all organisms are basically
the same
the ones that came out of the cambrian
explosion
you have very few different life forms
it's very small number they look diverse
when you don't understand them
same about languages when you go back
again about 50 or 60 years
it was commonly believed by
major professional linguists that
languages
differ so enormously
that each one has to be studied on its
own without any preconceptions
by now we know that that's totally false
it's very much like biology
if you get into the deeper parts of them
it turns out they're very much
cast to the same mold in fact if that
were not true
no child could ever learn the language
it's got to be
i mean what the child knows let's say
two or three years old
is way beyond any evidence that's been
presented
like one example that i gave for example
you can't learn that
and it turns out that these principles
are apparently uniform across across all
languages
i mean in a sense we know that they have
to be
otherwise language couldn't be learned
so the task of the field is
to show what we know must be true
that is to find the the
mold to which all of these things are
cast
it's got to be there we have to find it
and the more you look
the more you find it it's even for the
meanings of words
um the meaning of a word is
so rich that you could never pick it up
from exposure
and in fact we know that children learn
words from almost
no exposures at the peak period of
language learning two or three years old
the kid is picking up a word virtually
every waking hour
which means almost one exposure and they
know
the rich and complex meaning
now the things that you were talking
about like irregardless
they're on the order of table manners i
mean
it's like how should we behave you know
and
you talk differently when you're giving
a formal lecture than
when you're talking to somebody on the
street
so we learn those uh
conventions about how you're supposed to
talk in different places but they are
they have almost nothing to do with
language the point is to understand the
word regardless
requires enormous internal knowledge
you don't have anywhere near enough
evidence in your entire life
to acquire by induction anything like
the meaning of the word regardless
or in fact anything like the word river
or tree
uh almost any word you look at soon as
you begin to study
deeply what their meanings are turns out
it's
way beyond anything you get from the
environment
so the they're the same in all languages
so
they have it kind of has to be the case
otherwise you learn
couldn't learn anything uh but so again
it's kind of like if i look at an x-ray
i see just a lot of noise if a
radiologist looks at it
they see a tumor in a certain place well
the infant is like the radiologist
they're genetically primed to look for
particular things
so they miss the noise and go after the
particular things
and that's true of word meaning it's
true of every aspect of language
you're so now we're going to switch
gears a little bit and talk about
consciousness and maybe segway if you
have time
into discussion of artificial
intelligence and language
natural language processing and i have
some questions related to those and
hopefully
maybe be able to tie them together in
the cognitive
scientific miasma that i want to
to construct but in your 2017 talk at
the science of consciousness yield here
in san diego
uh sponsored by the university of
arizona where you're currently located
uh you have some uh very interesting
perspectives in which
at various times i felt hopeful and at
various times i felt hopeless and i'll
say
there's this running debate it's the
so-called hard problem of consciousness
and the easy problem of consciousness
and there are those that believe that
there's consciousness in every um and
subatomic particles perhaps
depending on what what definition one
uses for consciousness
but i want to start with the very
beginning when you uh really tied into
something very important to me uh which
is the scientific method
and of course you're extremely well
known for using
the scientific method you know first in
the cognitive revolution
to use and study cognition in its own
right for the first time
in that talk you coined a term called
the galilean
challenge do you remember can you
explain what
that uh what the relevancy of that topic
is why
what was galileo talking about as the as
this fundamental challenge that
came from language and perhaps
superseded the challenges that he had
employing the physical the scientific
method perhaps
first of all one scientific method
i'm sure in your physics department
there isn't a course on scientific
now yes there is no scientific method
it's just
being intelligent you know
i've never once sat down and said i'm
going to form a hypothesis i'm going to
assemble an apparatus
we do it in our lab classes but you're
absolutely right yeah there is no and
some believe there is no scientific
method period not not only that
in in practice do we not use it but at
first
method is making smart conjectures
and seeing if they work by looking at
the data
in some scientific method in a nutshell
but
the galileo remember this is the
beginning of the scientific revolution
17th century
and there was a real revolution let me
go back to
neoscholastic physics they had an answer
to everything
so you know you're holding a
glass of water with hot boiling water
your hand over it you let it go the
glass falls the steam rises
we have an answer they're going to their
natural place
you pick a big lead bowl and a small
lead bowl
and you drop them the big one is going
to go faster because that's our
experience
you perceive a triangle of the form of
the triangle
goes through the air and implants itself
in your brain
well the scientific revolution began
when people decided to be puzzled about
those things
they said why should i believe any of
this in fact as soon as you think about
it some of them are wrong
like the greater fall galileo
disproved it by thought experiments
never carried out any experiments
but it was able to show you obviously
it's false
one of the things they looked at and the
same with the rest that's when the
scientific revolution began well one of
the things they looked at was language
they were puzzled by that
and what galileo and others were puzzled
by
in fact regarded as
kind of an amazing incomprehensible fact
is that with a few symbols
we somehow are able to construct
infinitely many thoughts in our mind
and even find a way to
get others who have no access to our
minds
to comprehend what riff of the inner
workings of our mind
that's what that's a miracle you know
yeah they're right it's a
very hard problem you don't know how to
solve but that's the galilean challenge
how can that take place
up to the present and now we have
parts of it that we can understand other
parts remain mysterious
so um you speak uh in these talks on
consciousness
about sort of this internal system and
external system
or the you know the system of making
something external
can you explain what do you exactly mean
by internal system
is it is it it sounded slightly
uh ill-defined in that it's it's very
difficult to say well here's my internal
system and
a mechanistic reductionist point of view
but what do you mean by the internal
system and the interaction
to make it very precise i mean we're
just talking loosely but if we start
with the
simplest combinatorial operation as i
said binary set formation
we ask how it applies we take a look at
some other conditions
so for example there's good reasons to
believe that the way the brain works
it keeps the principles of computational
efficiency you have some understanding
of those you bring those in
it tries to limit the use of resources
so so for example one of the striking
things about the brain
is that it's extremely slow uh
if you look at the visual system say the
retina
a single cell of the retina is picking a
photon of light
yes it's passing a huge amount of
information
into the system but the brain is much
too slow to
deal with it so it throws almost all of
it out
of some way of keeping the resources
limited
to try to work out these notions of
resource limitation uh
computational efficiency other things
you pretty soon
begin to get sharper ideas about how the
internal system is working and you can
make it
quite precise then comes the question
how is it coded in the brain
that's the next question notice that's a
very hard question
for ethical reasons not for scientific
reasons
remember that the language system is
unique
to humans we can't study other organisms
they don't have it right so the kinds of
invasive experimentation
that have been used to lead to
understanding of the neurology the
visual system
can't be carried out now we can't carry
out experiments with say
children in isolation and see what would
happen
ethical reason so you have to in order
to study
something that's unique to humans almost
all the modes of direct experimentation
are excluded
they're just not allowed to do it for
ethical reasons
yeah that was sort of related to the you
know thought experiment
of communicating with an alien that you
would avoid presumably the
ethical implications although i'm sure
there were awful experiments done during
the nazi regimes
on living subjects and maybe not in the
era where we could appreciate their
impact on consciousness or whatever but
yeah you're right that is that is a
difficult there's no true uh
way to to you know provide a null
hypothesis with which to
compare um is there is there in physical
could be clear
yeah you do neuro linguistics
got to be smart about it experiment i
mentioned at the beginning about uh the
impossible and possible languages and
their
brain correlates that's neurolinguistics
okay so you can figure out indirect ways
to learn
things but you can't do the experiments
that immediately come to mind
like sticking an electrode in broca's
area and see what happens
you just can't do that but
but you can do it indirectly it's a
little like cosmology
you can't go back a couple billion years
and say
i'd like to see what's happening not yet
and it's very much like that but you can
learn things
so going back to your question at the
level of
the computational system and how it
works
you can get fairly precise when you ask
how is it coded in the brain somehow
you're running into very hard problems
which
are limited because you can't do the
experiments and come to mind you have to
do
indirect experiments so there it
you know becomes harder but these are
all within the bounds of scientific
inquiry
in science uh again turning back to
feynman but but even back to for matt
and and others uh there's a notion of
what's called the principle of least
action which is
an expression of parsimony in nature
that the shortest paths
geodesic paths are taken in physical
systems that minimize a certain quantity
called the action which in turn is
related to certain
dynamical variables that characterize a
phys system in physics
is there an analog and that's one of by
the way the most you know
cherish sacred principles of all of
physics in fact it
halts for everything you know including
the propagation of light and quantum
electrodynamics and
quantum field theory even you know from
the 1600s up until
you know the modern day is there an
analog in linguistics i mean you
mentioned that we are forming thoughts
we have meta thoughts
uh we're throwing out a lot of data how
does the mind know how to do that
is there an analog to this principle of
least action
yeah computational efficiency principles
of computational efficiency are
analogs to the laws of least action and
they
show up very immediately in our i mean
let's take a sentence like
the boys expect to meet each other at
the beach
uh each other goes back to the boys
that picks the closest thing suppose you
say
which girls do the boys expect to meet
each other at the beach
each other doesn't go back to the boys
it goes back to something that's not
there
what's in your mind is which girls do
the boys expect
the girls to meet each other that's in
your mind
and each other goes back to the unheard
the girls but why don't you pronounce
the girls
principle of least effort the printer
wants to do as little as possible so it
eliminates a lot of stuff
it just does so minimal it can get away
with
it has to pronounce something where you
don't know the question was even asked
so it pronounces just the most prominent
thing none of the others
that leads to major problems in
communication
in fact for people who do automatic
parsing
one of the biggest problems is what are
called filler gap
problems you hear a word like
which girls you gotta find the place
where it's not there and that's it
for this sentence it's easy when you get
to more complicated sentences it can be
a huge
problem so because of computational
efficiency the
analog to the law of east action you're
getting huge compute
communication problems but the internal
system
is working with maximal efficiency it
doesn't erase anything that would be an
extra operation
that's done for so and in fact
this is related to the questions of into
what we call talking to ourself internal
language
we're not talking to ourself in inner
language
when you think the sentence which girls
did the boys expect to meet each other
you thinking it the way it's pronounced
you're not thinking what's going on in
your mind that's inaccessible to you
that can only be understood the way you
can understand how your visual system
works by
external investigation so almost all of
our thinking
is inaccessible we're only getting a
periphery of it what's around the
printer level
uh and what's really going on you have
to study as if
it's some physical system that you have
no access to
because there's no way it's
introspecting to it if you could
introspect linguistics would be really
easy
you just think what it is but you can't
do it because it's all
inaccessible now this bears on the
consciousness issue
because what we're conscious of is
little
bits and fragments that kind of
come out from whatever's going on inside
in fact if you really introspect and you
think
what's coming to your mind it's it's not
sentences
it's bits and pieces of this and that
and the other thing
you can make decisions very
quickly microseconds that are
complex decisions about a variety of
different things
like you walk into a room
see some guy sitting over there who you
wanted to say something to so you go
over to him but
you notice somebody else is sitting
there who will be insulted if you say it
so you decide not to and then you
decide to say something else and so on
but this happens
instantaneously but bits and pieces of
the conversation that you're having do
reach consciousness
so you'll get a fragment of this
fragment of that and so on
but reaches consciousness is a very
superficial partial reflection
of the internal computation that's going
on
that means if you want to seriously
study consciousness
you're going to have to learn about the
internal
processes that are putting forth
the bits and pieces that pass through
the
filter and reach consciousness very
small superficial amount
i hear some language from a mammal in
the background there
or working from home yeah i don't know
if that
if there's a way to uh i don't want to
muzzle the dog but
if the dog can uh can keep it down while
we're on the podcast that would be great
um so i want to turn now uh from
well consciousness in the state of uh
something you said
at the at the science of consciousness
uh actually you said this the sec
the next year in 2018 and i wonder you
know if there was a change between 2017
and 2018
perhaps not perhaps i missed it but um
you said
the following the inner workings of the
mind are inaccessible
to consciousness that's a very profound
statement what what do you mean exactly
by that and and
since i don't remember in 2017 you said
in 2018
maybe there's a chance you'd no longer
no longer maintain that statement but
you said the inner workings of the mind
are inaccessible to consciousness what
does that mean
i just gave an example the inner
workings of your mind for the sentence
that i gave
yeah produce the sentence which
girls the boys expected the girls
to meet each other that's inaccessible
we can find it indirectly by studying
the way
words like each other work they do
work by picking out the nearest element
that's again
least effort but they're doing it on
something that you can't be conscious
can't be conscious of any of the
operations that are taking place
so the inner workings it's very much
like the inner workings of your
like you have a gut brain yeah it's
called the enteric
nervous system nervous system that's
carrying out these huge operations for
the
keeping your body functioning you can't
introspect into it
um the only thing you know about it is i
have a stomachache
you know something's going wrong but and
it's very much the same with the
brain that's in our head we can see
little bits and pieces at the surface
but we can't figure out what
we can interest we were totally
unconscious of what's going on
and there's no way to become conscious
of it the same is true the meanings of
the simplest words
you know like take the first case that
was studied in
the history of science was heraclitus
the pre-socratic he asked a very
profound
question now how can you cross the same
river twice
okay you think about it not a trivial
question
the second time you cross it it's
totally different it's a different
variety same river you start playing
with this
you realize that you could make radical
changes
in the river it would still be the same
river
you can make tiny changes like
[Music]
a phase change that switches it to the
glassy state
and then run cars on it it's not a river
it's a highway
almost undetectable change but it's not
a river
huge changes it will still be a river
now every
infant knows this and it's very complex
when you look into it
you can't introspect into them you have
to do
experiments to figure it out like these
thoughts exotics
elements uh and that's with every word
in the language
and of all the constructions in the
language all the methods for
constructing the thoughts that we're
producing constantly
totally beyond the level of
consciousness
so so it may sound strange but if you
think about it for a minute it's kind of
almost obvious
so we spoke about uh you know the
ethical implications
of of of testing you know consciousness
and impact and human cognition i want to
turn to
artificial intelligence now and ask you
first of all are there
applications uh that art or artificial
intelligence
uh could shed light or perhaps already
has shed light on these problems of
consciousness in your opinion
artificial intelligence divided into
two fields uh one of them which
marvinski was interested in was trying
to find out something about
the nature of intelligence that's
science it's indistinguishable from
cognitive science
it just happens to be using different
devices
so it's doing it by modeling with
computers instead of
modeling on paper but it's uh it's
basically some cognitive science
that's one part of artificial
intelligence
the other part is engineering trying to
construct something that's useful
like say a google translator it's done
by
brute force force
no scientific interest whatsoever kind
of low-level engineering
machine learning most of what's not in
deep learning
is brute force yes you try to do massive
computation of rapid computation of huge
amounts of data and
see if a pattern emerges okay
it's okay like a google translator is
useful i'm glad to have it
i'm glad to have a bulldozer but it's
not there's nothing to do with science
now if you ask about the language side
it wasn't possible to answer because the
part of a.i
the sort of minsky blood that's is
essentially indistinguishable from
cognitive science
so the answer is automatic language is
just part of it
now the other side doesn't have anything
to do with science
so it basically doesn't tell you
anything like if you have a word
processor
like one of mine you know there's a bit
part of it which is a pain in the neck
it constantly tries to predict the next
word you're gonna say
it's emotions because it gets no
f-typing
well that's an ai pedic learning program
you know you study massive amounts of
text with some super computer you
do a lot of statistical work you can get
a
pretty good prediction of what the next
word it's often going to be
it's totally meaningless and it's like
looking at
billions of chemical experiments and
getting to the point where you can
predict that if you
mix these two things it's going to turn
blue okay
don't tell anything about chemistry
that's just nonsense
right so that's one scientific
the other part is just science
and when we uh think about things well
first of all when i want to get back to
the predictive text
one of my friends is a very popular
podcaster named james altucher
he says that you know one day he was
doing that and he was frustrated by it
as it sounds like you are
uh but uh but then he realized actually
this ai was helping him be a better
natural human being intelligence in
other words it was it was telling them
things like
suggesting how are you you know what's
uh how is your day
and thank you so much and and these are
things that he wouldn't say
why are you bothering me but it was
actually um you know
humiliating or moderating some of his
more gruff
personality traits and and i wonder yes
it's a nuisance but
uh but then you know there are there are
you know
artificial intelligence has a role in in
some sense to do
uh to make predictions uh based on
experience and that experience can only
come through you know the brute force
approach
at least for now uh but i wonder you
know
in when we speak about artificial
general intelligence and
and so forth um it was a famous turing
test and and i wonder
um you know nowadays you've probably
seen there's these
captchas you know there are these images
where your computer
asks you to prove that you're a human
being it's sort of you know
an inverse turing type like you have to
prove you're a human being
to a computer uh which is sort of the a
little bit of
an inversion of the classical turing
test but uh does
you know does language uh play a crucial
role
in the turing test like i can't imagine
my two-year-old
you know being able to tell the
difference between
a decent you know ai that one of my st
you know undergraduates could program
versus the most sophisticated deep mind
that you know google might have
currently
uh so it seems to me that the ability to
pass the turing test
almost is dependent on the cognition and
language abilities
of the human operant at the terminal
what do you feel about the
turing test as a as this modality
distinguished
uh general artificial intelligences
well let's begin by asking what turing
thought about it
so if you look back at his famous 1950
paper
on machine thinking he says the question
whether
machines can think is too meaningless
to deserve discussion okay
that's what turing thought about it he
thought that the
imitation game as he called it could be
a useful device for
stimulating construct better
construction of machines of software and
so on
i said it might in 50 years and just
modify the way we think about thinking
but it's a question where the machines
can think is too meaningless to deserve
discussion it's kind of like asking
whether submarines can swim
they want to call that swimming okay
they can swim
in fact language is different in some
languages
airplanes fly and other languages they
glide
you know that's uh these are just
uninteresting conventions now you take
the turing test itself
and go back to the 17th century the
origins of modern science
they had something like the during test
uh
descartes asked the quest he was part of
this
galilean challenge was galileo and many
others
descartes asked how can
a person carry out
the normal creative use of language
you know what to say in particular
circumstances
you're producing sentences constantly
which are novel you never heard before
nobody ever heard them before
but others can understand them they're
appropriate to situations
but they're not caused by situations you
could have said something else
so it's not as they put it you're
you're inclined to say certain things
but not
impelled this property
of being able to and then some of his
followers
jacques courtemois another cartesian
proposed test experimental tests said
suppose there's another creature that
looks like us we want to find out if he
has a mind like ours
so we run experiments not to
ask him that would he say the kind of
thing that's
appropriate in particular circumstances
that's the turing test
but it was different in the 17th century
there
it was science for them remember
it's a question of existence
there's a mind which is a thing in the
world
there's a body which is a thing in the
world we want to know whether another
creature
has the mind it's like asking does he
have a liver
you know it's asking a question of the
physical sciences
that's right for the cartesians for the
galileans
the analog of the turing test it's a
straight
scientific question for touring it's not
a scientific question
it's a way of stimulating your
imagination or something like that
so in a way the 17th century tests were
much more serious
uh but this you know
going back to your you know your
computer that tells you something yeah
that's fine
i mean if alexa helps you to think of
something who cares
but there's no science involved right
it's like saying
my electric stove works
is that uh does that parlay with or you
know
dovetail with your well-known views on
the
elon musk's neuralink project where
you've said that
you know trying to move your arm uh
you know with a neuro embedded chip like
neurolink
is perhaps feasible at some point but to
find out what you're thinking
uh there seems to be you claimed in in
2018 i believe
that there's no way to do that because
we don't understand how to proceed and i
think that
i don't think your views have changed
much right right that we don't even know
if we're looking at the right thing
how thinking may not involve neural nets
in fact there's pretty good reason to
believe that it doesn't the neural nets
for one thing or
neural transmission is pretty slow as we
were
you know by the relevant corrector
by the criteria of what we were talking
about before
how rapidly you think by that
criterion is known back to helmholtz in
fact
the neural transmission is pretty slow
furthermore
neural nets don't have the right at
the right architecture you have to
what we need is something like touring
architecture
some something that has basically the
control unit of a touring machine you
know right
dress you can't do that in the world
that's
they just don't have the right
properties that's why
stuart hammer off what you mentioned
before is uh
looking at things like microtubules
uh things in the the internal structure
of a neuron
which has vastly more computing power
roger prenrose is working on this main
work on it was done by
randy galliston very good neuroscientist
who's
done very interesting work arguing what
i just said i'm just quoting him
that the neural net systems are just the
wrong place to look
they don't have the kind of architecture
which is involved in thinking
we have to find something else it might
turn out to be at the molecular level
with the level of rna you know molecular
level
you're really getting massive
possibilities of computation
so maybe just duplicating a neural net
will tell you nothing
because you're not looking in the right
place we don't know
i mean the thing to do is do the science
first then
worry about the engineering
so i wonder now if we can turn to
the topic of of the university in
academia
and i always like to ask guests such as
yourself who are
uh public intellectuals plus
academicians for
many many decades uh i want to ask you
uh what you see as the future of the
university
um and especially in this era of covid
and and so forth
uh and then after that a follow-up
question will be if there was a chomsky
university what would you have on offer
there
well i would treat it the wave
old friend of mine a physicist who you
know very well
at mit treated vicky vice cup
and his he was famous in his freshman
introductory courses when a kid would
ask him
that what are we going to cover in the
semester he would say it doesn't matter
what we cover
it matters what you discover
that's what an educational system should
be
and i think you can extrapolate from
that
in every direction so the worst kind of
education imaginable
is what's called teaching to test what
we do in the schools
every one of us knows you've had a
boring course where you
bothered to learn the stuff and you aced
the test and a week later you forgot
what the course was about
okay that's what we impose on children
the worst possible kind of education
the right kind is what vice cup was
talking about
so the right kind of education let's
stay in a science course
and there are very good programs there's
one example
take a kindergarten and give the kids
each kid in the kindergarten is given a
shell
and on the show there are several things
a bead you know a piece of grass
a seed and a bunch of things and then
the teacher poses a problem that which
one of these
is going to grow okay and then the kids
have a
scientific conference they try to figure
out some way to decide
which ones can get would grow a little
supervision from the teacher you know
sort of keep it in the right direction
but finally they
figure out you know one way to do it is
put it in the earth
and water it now they finally figured
that and finally they've
figured out how to do it and something
grows then at the end the kid
the teacher gives them each a microscope
and splits the seed in half
you can see what's inside it that's
making it grow
that's education okay teach it to test
you could say here's the answers learn
them repeat them in a test
zero effect you know you don't
personally you don't learn anything
and you don't understand how to learn
which is the most important thing
i should say all of these topics were
discussed in the 17th and 18th century
and they used the model of uh
pouring water into a vessel one kind of
teaching
the kind they said it's absolutely no
good right you don't want to just pour
water into a vessel that's useless
uh the right kind was
actually described by wilhelm von
humboldt founder of the modern research
university
what it is is the teacher lays out a
string
along which the student follows
in his or her own way with some
structure and guidance but
one of the best math courses i ever took
in my life a graduate
course in real variables another
very good mathematician university of
pennsylvania
he would come into the class and clean
the blackboard and
write something down on the blackboard
and say is that a
and the rest of the class would be
trying to figure out if that's a theorem
based on
our reading for you know so can you get
a limit from which it would be proven
maybe so can you figure out a way to do
that
and that's education and you can do it
at every level
from kindergarten humanities
yeah i agree that as you said the
you know the the analogy of pouring
water into a vessel
literally the word educate comes from
latin educare
which means to draw out as i remember
which is kind of in concert with with
exactly the way you're describing it my
friend mario olivio who's an
astrophysicist at
johns hopkins and space telescope
research institute he has a book called
you know why what makes us curious and
he claims you know epistemic curiosity
is the key to education and in fact
you know that instead of teaching your
kid you know why
uh the inverse square law of gravity he
says no don't start with that start with
dinosaurs you know ask them
do you know how the dinosaurs died and
every kid loves dinosaurs and they're
going to want to know and
especially tell them an asteroid you
know is
likely the reason for their demise and
and then you're just increasing the
level of
of tension in the spring and it just
wants to unwind uh so badly and release
that that is the way to educate and yet
we're stuck in this
model i mean the modern university
system is you know far better than i am
and it goes back
thousand years to bologna and and
perhaps before
in the 10 in the you know end of the
beginning of the
second millennium and i wonder you know
that hasn't
changed and and i wonder with things
like ai and
you're obviously not a super as as your
colleague
former colleague at mit max tag mark is
as as
perhaps as anglin about the benefits or
the future potential of ai
um and yet you know why should somebody
take a class with
brian keating in physics at uc san diego
when he or she
someday could take a class with galileo
himself
or marie curie or or whoever
is there is there a needed change in the
university system to break the sage on a
stage
you know scratching one rock of chalk on
another blackboard rock
is is this model due for a change or do
you feel like
the in-person learning model that we've
had for a thousand years will
persist well first of all i think
in the best cases it does persist like
the cases i mentioned
the math class i took vice cops
physics class air gordon case and many
others
i was at mit most of my life i'm now at
the university of arizona
and there's an interesting change it's
very old-fashioned
yes i was able to use black words and
chalk no no it's not chalk it's some
other
gimmick but you could write things on a
blackboard and you come to
i've noticed from talking at other
universities in here
you got to use powerpoint yes
okay i can sort of learn how to use it
i find it much easier just to go to the
blackboard and think
you know maybe what i thought about the
powerpoint isn't what i feel
talking about and also interact
so the student comes up with something
you can write in the blackboard and
let's talk about that
it's uh i i think you know
i'm not entranced by these educational
advances i'm not sure
young people seem to like them it's kind
of
key to the video culture that they live
in
even i even see students like it if the
professor
has a powerpoint and reads off the thing
on the
on the screen i don't understand that
i like it the way my old math teacher
did it
but i i don't think the
that's really the issue with the
universities i mean you can
do a good class anyway but it's the
question whether
like the person you just mentioned are
you going to encourage
curiosity or dull it i mean
the children are naturally curious
they're always asking why does it work
this way
what's the answer and so on now you can
either stimulate that curiosity
or kill it and unfortunately a lot of
the educational system kills it
yeah but it doesn't have to can
stimulate it
in all the ways we've been talking about
yeah and that's
if you're a country school house a
little red schoolhouse
just a blackboard and chalk and
everything every grade together you can
do it there
you can live in a fancy university uh
classroom with all kind of
kind of extra bells and whistles that
you can push
uh here's a random question for you um
have you ever meditated
and i'll explain why in a second have
you ever meditated
say if you don't have time for it then
you need to do three hours a day
uh so the reason i ask is that one and
i've tried this
and it's become increasingly popular in
many different realms from even the
military to
you know to um you know peak performers
not just for deepak chopra who helped
helped us meditate when we were at the
science of consciousness
together and part of the goal is to
stop your inner monologue and and i
wonder you know there are those that
claim
when you do such a thing you achieve
enlightenment and i'm not such a huge
fan of that
but um but the mass industry of the
meditation industry literally
millions billions of dollars perhaps
apps and books and seminars and gurus
and mantras um
i've tried to you know dial into what it
really means and it seems like you're
trying to stop the inner monologue
you're trying to stop this incessant
fire hose
and it's almost as if the human being is
is some are ashamed of it or
it's negative in a way that you know
saying we're much more comfortable
talking about you know sex or you know
things that are
uh used to be taboo maybe but people
don't go around saying every thought
that they have
and i wonder why is that why why why is
the inner monologue sort of the last
taboo that
you know these these incessant thoughts
that are bombarding every human brain
why is that so taboo to speak about or
is it maybe it's not
i work on the inner mind all the time
students of language that's what they're
doing studying
visual perception that's what you're
doing uh anything in the cognitive
sciences you're studying the inner mind
if what you're talking about you know
the bits
the bits of trifold we're not aware of
there are ones
we're only aware of bits and fragments
that
come out every once in a while there's a
machine there
that spits out a little bit of this and
that that's what we're aware of
but it's not the inner line the inner
mind you can only study
from the outside as it's the same way
you study the
gut brain can't no introspection
uh but uh sure we can study on the other
hand
why don't you go around talking
constantly whatever's on your mind well
there are people who do they're called
children
and if you listen to your three-year-old
kid they're talking constantly
anything that's on their mind they're
saying you know they haven't learned and
keep it quiet yet so it's okay with a
two-year-old it would be a
pretty awful world of 40 year old
i keep my inner child and and permanent
time out
um so we're almost done here i
appreciate your time so much i want to
just finish up with a question from a
friend of mine an intellectual
as well mathematician eric weinstein um
and it kind of relates to you know this
perception of you as this
controversial figure uh and and just
recently there was a letter that you
were a co-signatory of
i believe the title of it is a letter on
justice and open debate
and you and jk rowling were the two you
know kind of featured
uh co-signatories although there were
hundreds of people
over 100 people and i i wonder what um
and eric weinstein asks the following
question will liberalism survive
this diversity movement or the moment
that you guys were
sort of decrying in this letter um that
you wrote the open letter
on justice and debate first of all let
me
mention turn to the point that we were
the doom engine
that's a sign of the utter irrationality
incurable irrationality of the
intellectual culture
anybody who thinks for one second
can see that you don't evaluate a
statement
by the signers if you did there would
never be a statement for a very simple
logical reason
i'm sure you get plenty of statements
you're asked to sign
you don't know who's going to sign them
later so if you
care about who's going to sign a letter
you'd never decide
so therefore there wouldn't be any
statements at all so even to pay
attention to the assignments reveals
profound irrationality what matters is
the content
of the statement makes no difference who
signs it
for elementary reasons of elementary
logic
just what i just said yeah so i don't
care who signed it
you can't know who's going to sign it's
impossible the center
company the fact that this anodyne
statement
received the flood of reaction is very
interesting
it's a simple straightforward statement
almost
too elementary to sign it says what
everybody ought to believe that doesn't
mean it's not important to say
um there are different tendencies in the
university and you're all familiar with
them which are
limiting discussion we can say that's
not a good thing
period there shouldn't be one article in
any newspaper referring to it
okay the fact that there's the only
interesting thing about the statement is
the reactions
why are there reactions to such an
elementary comment
and why do they focus on signers when if
anybody thinks for a moment
if they can figure out that if you could
pay attention to signers there'd never
be a statement
on anything you know okay so i think
we're looking at an
interesting case of the radical
irrationality
of the intellectual culture it's about
the only interesting thing to say about
this
so is there hope do you feel that the
this irrationality is
is uh going to is on the upswing so to
speak
from your perspective or is it is it
likely to dissipate
and and what role if any does
linguistics or or
have to say about it i'll mention why in
a second i said that but do you find
it's
it's diminishing or do you feel for fear
for the worst that it's going to get
more and more
ideologically entrenched that even these
anodyne statements
in your words cannot be countenanced
well
i think there's an interesting thing
going on
uh you go back to earlier years there
was a very high degree of uniformity
so for example i could give you examples
from my own experience
but anything that shifted a little bit
from
the ideological mainstream was just
them get in now there's been
a good thing that's happened is there's
more concern for
other issues that weren't talked about
before
uh women's rights rights of blacks
you know uh human rights general a lot
more
a diversity now one of the effects of
diversity
is it can be overdone so
you're getting a kind of a confluence
and
uh it's got good things
it's got bad things that we should be
rational enough to pick out and
emphasize and develop
good things and put to the side the bad
things
and the question is up to us can we do
that
do you feel that there is a role that
perhaps linguistics might be uniquely
capable of our language in general might
be
capable of uh uprising in
in the sense that you know it's it's
sort of a a trope or whatever that when
you hear an accent from some play you
know the south
it's it's you know there's jeff
foxworthy makes a bunch of jokes about
this he's from the south he'll say you
know
the last thing you want is your brain
surgeon to say yeah what you're gonna do
is go down and cut open
you know and they may be fully qualified
and you know he's uh
he's joking about that but there is you
know in in some of that there's a
stereotype that certain accents sound
uneducated
uh british english for example sounds
sophisticated even if the person who's
uttering the words might be
uh a total ignoramus um why why does
why do we have these reactions i mean
why why
is that encoded why do we encode a
prejudice
based on the sound not even you know
it's a meta form of the language itself
not even the structure of grammar
it's much more than language uh if you
go to a
formal party dressed the way you are now
it would be improper yeah not because
it's wrong
just because that's the convention okay
so there are
a uh hierarchies of power and authority
which say you got to behave like me
so you don't talk with a southern
cracker accent
in a you know in a formal occasion
it's not it's we shouldn't accept it's
it's not a problem of language
it's a problem of the authority
structures they shouldn't have that
authority
you say it's only your business how i
talk you know i talk the way i talk
by and that's the authority structure of
this
issue so let's go after that not the
superficial symptom
like what clothes you wear or you know
did you comb your hair the right way
you know that you remember to shave this
morning or whatever that
says of no interest what are you saying
that's what matters
kind of like this statement what's in it
not who decided to sign it uh that's uh
we have to just overcome these
prejudices
now they're like a lot of others you
know
a lot of them are quite pernicious a lot
of them we have overcome
things you could that were considered
quite normal
not many years ago are considered
totally unacceptable now
uh plenty of them and that's good
but we can't overdo it you can't get to
the point where
nothing can be said without the
tiptoeing on eggshells
you know you've got to find the right
boundary between those and that holds
not only for language but for
all kinds of behavior yeah i don't think
linguistics really has anything to say
other than
every language is the same as every
other language which okay that's true
yeah like if all the power were in the
hands of those southern crackers we
have to talk like that uh so
uh numb there's two more questions if
you'll beg my
uh indulgence here uh the first question
that i like to ask all my guests
on the into the impossible podcast
relates to sir arthur c
clarke's book 2001 a space odyssey and
made into a film
by stanley kubrick you'll probably
remember in the film
there were these monoliths there were
these uh very imposing
uh objects that were found on the
african savannah
by some primates and then later found on
the the moon's surface
and they're allegedly left in the book
series they're left as
a as sort of a a way to communicate
messages to humanity placed by an
ancient civilization that was obviously
far advanced of where we are now but
meant to be discovered at a certain time
when humans were capable say of going to
the moon
for example and so my question for you
the first of these two questions
relates to a time capsule if you were
able to
make a time capsule that was going to
last a billion years
like this monolith uh what would you put
on it or
in it or what what synoptic view would
you
like to engrave and code and crypt into
such an object to last for a billion
years
well actually that problem is very real
since it's very likely that humans will
extinguish themselves
within a couple of generations the
problem is very much alive
either nuclear war or environmental
catastrophe if we
continue on our present course we're not
going to survive
so the question is not abstract
uh the uh what we should put first the
first thing we should do is try to see
if we can avert those
outcomes it's still time to do it that's
the major question in human history
okay i suppose we can't what you put in
them is
the greatest works of science of
art of literature
any aspect of human achievement see
that's what you people a billion years
now from now
and should be striving for on some
planet maybe not this one
that's right and the last question gnome
uh
involves going backwards in time not
forwards in time
and as i mentioned the name of this
podcast is called the into the
impossible podcast
in uh allusion to sir arthur c clarke's
third law so-called third law which
states the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
and accordingly i would like to know in
your life what
aspect of your life perhaps you know as
a 20 year old a 30 year old as a young
academic what perplexed you seemed
impossible
uh and then uh makes sense to you now in
with the retrospective time
uh so what sorts of in uh advice would
you give to your former self perhaps
as a 20 or 30 year old
let me give the advice that i in fact
gave to myself
at the time the field went in didn't
exist
in fact the first book i published
submitted mit press and got a very
sensible
reviewer reaction saying this field
doesn't exist this
can't publish it was right you know but
the advice i didn't bother giving advice
i just said i don't care i'm gonna do
what looks interesting
and that's the right advice if it
doesn't work
too bad it does work okay
uh what looked impossible at the time
was what we were talking about
at the time it looked as if languages
just
differed totally from one another each
one had to be looked at it alone
in its own way when you think about it
that
can't be true plus if it were true
nobody could ever learn language since
what they know
is way beyond any evidence so there's a
real paradox
and it didn't seem to be any way to
solve it
in fact i think by now we're just about
getting to the point where
maybe we can find an answer to it all
right well i hope to have you back on
the podcast when that happy day comes uh
but for now gnome i want to thank you
for your
time i want to wish you uh a happy and
maybe
cool summer in arizona i don't know if
that's
that's that's impossible perhaps uh to
envision but
we got below 100.
very good gnome thank you so much for
joining us on the into the impossible
podcast
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
in the division of physical sciences at
the university of california san diego
eric very director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valco